MAX SALTONSTALL: With almost
500 sessions at Next 2018,
it's understandable that you
couldn't get to them all.
So if you didn't see
Implementing Fintech
Security in the
Cloud, then stay tuned
because here's the rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Moving your company's
workloads to the public cloud
can be scary.
It feels like a
huge security risk,
and often, you're dealing
with your most closely
guarded intellectual property.
To succeed at migrating,
you need to figure out
how to protect your IP
from theft or attack,
while also making
sure your stakeholders
can get access to
the data they need.
Let's see how Two Sigma
did it, start to finish.
Based in New York, Two Sigma
is a tech-driven investment
company that's
moving to the cloud,
while also juggling the needs of
internal modelers, developers,
and security teams, alongside
external communities of users
and developers.
We'll walk through how they
created a secure Google Cloud
Platform architecture, opening
up new opportunities for scale
that they could not achieve
with on-premise solutions.
They begin, like any of
us, with a brand new GCP
account and a super
admin identity or two.
Of course, they have existing
on premise resources,
including their authoritative
identity provider,
in this case, Active Directory.
Then, they create a few
compute and storage resources.
Securing those cloud assets
requires good policies.
In this case, we'll use identity
and access management policies
to restrict who can
access storage buckets,
compute instances, and
both front and back end
applications, even before we
create any substantive content.
As we continue to build and
secure this architecture,
we repeatedly ask ourselves,
what have we secured
and what are the
existing concerns?
What's still vulnerable,
or what could be abused?
Where do we have opportunities
to improve our ability
to audit?
And how can we make things
easier for our stakeholders?
Let's take your
super admin accounts.
These are very, very powerful
and need strong protections
because they could do almost
anything with your data, which
is why leveraging
security keys is
essential for these
high value accounts.
Or maybe all accounts?
Security keys guard against
phishing more effectively
than alternate second factors.
That's because you can't fool a
security key with a fake domain
or a fake certificate.
We've seen tremendous benefits
at Google from using them,
and many clients utilize
this open standard
to safeguard their accounts too.
Even when accounts
are very secure,
people can leak your
company's data accidentally.
You can prevent this
with org-wide policies,
in this case,
preventing any resource
from be accessed by
anybody outside the domain.
Going even further, we've
created a virtual private cloud
construct inside
our GCP architecture
so that no app
data inside the VPC
can be accessed from
anything outside.
This creates a strong
network boundary
and prevents data from going
to another GCP project which
could leak it.
Keeping your data safe also
requires preventing employees
from exfiltrating data.
To prevent a malicious insider
from moving data from one GCP
resource to another, you
can restrict all resources
inside your VPC to be accessible
only to other resources
inside the same VPC.
On top of this, you can
use Identity-Aware Proxy
to allow specific
people to access the VPC
resources from anywhere
on the internet,
especially useful for
contractors or remote workers
who need to connect
to these systems
from outside your
office environment.
IAP restricts access
based on identity,
so you choose who gets access,
rather than getting access
based on where someone sits.
Now that you've got a
great security setup,
you're done, right?
If things do go wrong, and
they probably will sometime,
you'll need to find out
what happened and when.
We'll use Stackdriver
to manage logs, tracking
what happened every
step of the way
so you can investigate
after an incident.
To get a view of your
overall security status,
we'll use Cloud
Security Command Center
to aggregate your
security metrics
into a single dashboard.
And we'll use Forseti to
increase your automation
around security policy
application and monitoring
so new projects will adhere to
the same security standards.
Securing your GCP
resources relies
on layering policies and
good architecture practices
and is possible even if
you're starting from scratch,
as you've seen here.
Thanks for watching.
You can see the full talk
link in the description below.
Subscribe to the Cloud YouTube
channel for more Next Rewind
videos.
[MUSIC PLAYING]